monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur je
crois que vous avez peur de la jeunesse
quand elle s'est mobilisée pendant les
gilets jaunes vous l'avez réprimé à
genoux main sur la tête sans qu'aucun
policier ne soit sanctionné pour ce qui
s'est passé à Mantes-la-Jolie je crois
que vous avez peur de la jeunesse parce
que vous venez de recommencer alors que
les universités de Rennes 2 du Mirail de
la Sorbonne et que 200 lycées se sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui vous avez à
nouveau instrument instrumentaliser la
police comme un moyen de réprimer les
jeunes ce matin à Lille vous avez envoyé
la police réprimé les étudiants ce matin
au lycée racine vous avez envoyé des
policiers frappés au visage des lycéens
vous avez envoyé la police gazée au
lacrymogène des lycéens mineurs monsieur
le ministre 15 universités sont bloqués
aujourd'hui et 200 lycées sont mobilisés
les jeunes sont contre vous et votre
réforme des retraites cela ne mérite pas
que vous les condamniez à la violence
policière monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous me garantir que vous ne
ferez plus frapper gazez au lacr ymogène
où est bornier aucun lycéen mineur ou
aucun étudiant
je vous remercie la parole est à Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs débutez monsieur
le député je crois que bon j'ai peur que
vous n'aimez pas tellement la police
le 24
le 24 juin 2022 il faut dire que vous
déclariez c'est un fait que la police
tue le 31 mars vous rajoutiez comment ne
pas voir que les contrôles abusifs de la
police tu sur fond de refuses tempéré
les policiers abusent de leurs armes et
tu en conséquence le 8 septembre bref on
peut dire que les policiers n'ont pas
beaucoup de présomption d'innocence avec
vous ce qu'on peut dire c'est que ce
matin monsieur le député au lycée racine
il y a eu quatre interpellations et
personnes passées en garde à vue sur
l'autorité du procureur de la République
pour dégradation volontaire violence
commise en réunion violence contre les
policiers en effet quand c'est ce cas là
je vous garantis qu'il y aura des
interpellations pour le reste je crois
qu'en France tout le monde constate que
les manifestations se passent le plus
correctement du monde et c'est grâce aux
policier aux gendarmes
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Boyard
je n'ai pas de leçon à recevoir d'un
ministre qui instrumentalise la police à
des fins politiques je n'ai pas de leçon
à recevoir d'un ministre qui dit que la
police n'a jamais tué alors que c'est un
fait que la police tue je n'ai pas de
leçon à recevoir d'un ministre qui dit
qu'il n'y a pas de contrôle abusif en
raison de la couleur de peau je n'ai pas
de leçons à recevoir d'un ministre qui
dit qu'il n'y a jamais eu de débordement
après des refus d'obtempérer monsieur le
ministre vous voulez deux ans de vie aux
étudiants et à leurs parents avec votre
réforme des retraites vous affamez dans
les universités vous écrasez les lycéens
sous la pression de parcoursup vous les
condamnez par votre inaction climatique
vous les noyez dans les chômages et le
bas salaire vous pensiez qu'ils allaient
se laisser faire non et vous venez
d'admettre à demi-mots que vous alliez
continuer de les réprimer vous les
réprimer nous les soutenons étudiants
bloquer toutes les universités du pays
lycéen
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente on avait bien
compris le principe général de votre
question qui était ni finalement sur les
étudiants sur les jeunes mais qui vous
permettaient d'avoir sans doute vos
réseaux sociaux les 15 secondes comment
dire à rôle évoqué pour chacun d'entre
nous c'est à dire un petit moment vos
connaissances oui monsieur le député
vous faites vous êtes la caricature de
ce que j'essaie d'énoncer dans Le
Parisien c'est la bordélisation du pays
[Musique]
oui monsieur le député
ces propos seraient presque à prêter à
rire s'il n'était pas si grave de la
part de représentants de la nation mais
dans vos propos dans vos propos monsieur
le député vous avez redit ici dans le
temple démocratie que ceux qui gardent
notre sécurité qui meurt sur la balle de
terroristes qui meurt sur le couteau de
ceux qui attaquent les femmes et les
enfants qui attaquent nos concitoyens
les plus pauvres les policiers ces
petites gens ces ouvriers de la sécurité
pour parler comme le Parti communiste
que vous avez très longtemps abandonné
vous les réinsulter ici en disant qu'il
tue c'est une honte et se mépris social
qui est le vôtre monsieur le député
malheureusement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]